avez-vous un partenaire Hé ouais, elle
est décédée Je suis vraiment désolé d'apprendre
que
Javan a des enfants à charge âgés de moins de 20 ans
vivant avec vous savez papa c'est vraiment
important que nous le remplissions car
nous devons lancer le processus
excusez-moi Alice peut  J'ai un mot, s'il vous plaît,
donnez-moi juste 30 secondes, s'il vous plaît,
puis-je avoir un mot maintenant dans mon
bureau, merci Jésus,
pas de problème, maman, vraiment, c'est moi qui
devrais être désolé que vous continuiez votre
travail, allez,
vous savez que nous en avons parlé.  avant
ce n'est pas acceptable je pense que tu sais
dans ce cas c'est tout à fait raisonnable
Oh